while several of president Trump's
allies called his UN speech today one of
his best-ever many in the mainstream
media had a different take he read the
president's words he said the conditions
for totally destroying North Korea would
be a force to defend ourselves and our
allies you could read that possibly to
even open up a justification for
preventive war against North Korea that
is a potential justification but the
words totally destroying a nation of 25
million people that borders on the
threat of committing a war crime why
does he have to be so provocative all
the time millions of people this is not
baby stuff this is a guy who was leading
The Apprentice as now is talking about
nuclear war I can't take it look this
wasn't a speech this was a sermon and he
wasn't a president he was a preacher up
there given his dark worldview about
threats and conflict a war crime dana
perino is that a fair criticism well
it's interesting that does anyone
actually say that kim jeong-hoon is
threatening a war crime when he says
he's gonna destroy the United States and
for guys like because retaliation would
not be a war crime I don't think in the
history of the country of the world that
retaliation against innocent people
would be a war crime so I think that
some in the media and I understand this
still relitigate for themselves their
coverage in the lead up to the Iraq war
mhm and I actually think that the
intelligence here is not in question no
there's no he can see it I think this is
a very different situation
Kimberly yeah you knew this was gonna
happen he gives a very very pro-american
pro-human speech which was well received
by most people but the media seizes on
the one assertive comment he makes about
North Korea mm-hmm
come on well I would imagine that they
thought carefully when they put that
line in there and it's based on their
intelligence gathering and what they
know it works with him this has become a
full-time job dealing with the Rocketman
like he has a funny name but he's a
really bad guy right the only solace is
he won't live forever but you know beat
that
family carrying on in the way that they
have you know he's just as bad probably
even worse more impetuous and impulsive
and radical than his father murdered
everybody in his family pretty much at
this point and the way he eats too you
can't live forever I'm worried that he's
gonna like the nickname like ya know so
a man because he'd like you know he
loves American pop culture play loves
Elton John he's like yeah that's the
image of being a Rocket Man and it's the
way he translates it to his people it
was probably like I am the greatest
person that ever word it was to walk
this earth Trump made a bad nickname
choice Dana I actually think the person
like never read about you this one you
like I like ones that are not about
Americans behind the scenes right here
like this is the greatest I'm Dennis
water treat like this pay royalty to
Elton John and Bernie Taupin
for using the nickname because that's
quite possible it's it's not surprising
to see people react with hysteria right
and they haven't quite gotten the
concept that that's not the best way to
counter this president if you're going
to level a critique do it calmly and
rationally and they never are capable of
restraining themselves to step back for
a minute and even do some basic
fact-checking
you know Terry Moran's going off there
half-cocked and all of a sudden he's an
international lawyer yeah ready to to
frog March them to the Hague and I think
that might be putting the cart and in
front of the horse is the rhetoric the
most delightful thing I've ever my life
I know but here's the the problem
nothing else has worked and even
libertarian that I have spoken to they
talk about the fact that you've got a
guy never mind intelligence you've got a
guy who's armed
he's got nuclear weapons and he's
talking about hitting American targets
he's talking about annihilating our
country he's telegraphing that himself
and he demonstrated the capability here
they're going further in in length in
terms of distance and capability so it's
a real threat all right Juan well I mean
I I think that the question is our
behavior I don't think there's any doubt
about what Kim jong-un's up to I think
everybody thinks that he's you know
loose screw or whatever you want to say
about it
what strikes me is when the president
who previously was talking about fire
and fury and never I said oh well look
it squawk on that well it didn't calm
down in fact there been more tests than
ever now and with hired grade of
ammunition in the missiles and going
farther and more of a threat to our
allies in the region so now he comes
back and he says you know what we're
gonna totally destroy them
so now media on the left from we were
perspective from my perspective just
people who are media said wow that's
kind of you know incendiary language
talking about nuclear war and then
everybody said no no no it's not nuclear
war but it is that's what he's talking
about and you know what if you're gonna
destroy them then you have to think
about consequence but again this is
President Trump who loves not only
nicknames which i think is an act of
genius line is where he gets the
greatest thing but at this point you've
got it then say well what's Russia gonna
say but what's China you're gonna go in
there and destroy people South Korea's
right there Japan's right there what are
you saying is this just for an American
audience this is Steve Miller the same
star this is another version of you know
the inaugural address with all kinds of
harsh language or is it for a world
stage and I want to give him credit for
being the American leader on the world
stage
it's hard sometimes well if anything is
incendiary it's the Rocket Man